it is a universal truth that all
religions whether their adherents want
to admit it or not change and evolve
over time and space
as a religion enters a new cultural
sphere it inevitably is going to adjust
and change based on that meeting
Buddhism is of course no different and
is indeed a religion where this
phenomenon is very clearly visible
Buddhism for different reasons has
really had an ability to diversify and
adapt existing religious and cultural
features in different parts of the world
into its own symbolic sphere
it won't be news to anyone that Buddhism
in different parts of the world can look
well very different and in East Asia
where Buddhism has arguably been the
strongest and most widespread across
history there are some really unique and
fasting features that are well unique to
that particular region and the Buddhism
that flourished and developed there and
one of the most significant and
influential schools of Buddhism across
history and today from East Asia is the
tradition known as Chan Buddhism also
known perhaps more widely by its
Japanese name Zen Buddhism
foreign
[Music]
most westerners think about Buddhism
they imagine a religion primarily
concerned with silent sitting meditation
and perhaps with the famous Quran
riddles
all of these perceptions of Buddhism
come from the influence of a single
Branch or School of Buddhism Zen
Buddhism
indeed the image most quote-unquote
westerners have of Buddhism is shaped
perhaps by primarily at least by two
things Zen Buddhism and Tibetan Buddhism
not only are these two very different
from each other there are also only two
schools within a religious tradition
that is much more diverse and complex
than that
so much has this particular kind of
Buddhism entered Western Consciousness
that the word zen itself has become a
kind of go-to word to describe something
or someone that is in a calm or
meditative content state that isn't to
say that it isn't an important part of
Buddhism which it absolutely is Zen is
and has been one of the most widespread
popular and prominent schools of
Buddhism in East Asia in places like
Japan in Korea where it is called son in
Vietnam where it is known as Tien and in
China where it originated and where it
is known as Chan
this word chan is actually a Chinese
version of the originally Sanskrit term
vyana which is usually translated as
something like meditation
and this name thus gives us the first
clue to the characteristics of this
tradition just like many people might
assume it is a form of Buddhism very
much focused on practice and on
meditation practice in particular
there were other prominent schools of
Buddhism including the popular Chinese
Tian Thai that were much more Scholastic
in nature focusing on translated
Buddhist texts and commentaries and
interpretations of those texts to reach
a kind of correct Doctrine
Chan appeared as a reaction to that and
with a much different focus on
teacher-student transmission and actual
experience and practice direct
experience and practice taught by a
teacher to a student in this kind of
lineage of teachers but we should
probably back up a little bit first
before we dive into Chan itself
I assume you know the basics of Buddhism
since we don't have time to go through
that properly here the religion
originated in India with the figure
Siddhartha Gautama known as the Buddha
or the enlightened one
he taught the four noble truths that
life is suffering or dissatisfaction
duka in in Pali that there is a reason
for a solution to that suffering and
offered a technique of ending that
suffering a state or concept known as
Nirvana
which according to many isn't actually a
state at all but anyways this technique
of ending duka involves the so-called
eight-fold path and adherence to the
three jewels or three Treasures of
Buddhism the Buddha as a kind of
Exemplar the Dharma or the teachings of
the Buddha and the Sangha the Buddhist
community
for a really great introduction to
Buddhism as a whole check out my friend
and fellow religious studies content
creator Andrew Henry's amazing videos on
the channel religion for breakfast which
are again simply fantastic
in any case after the death of the
Buddha Buddhism sped far and wide and
became very popular first in India
itself of course but before long it had
spread to other parts of the world
including China where it became a
dominant religious tradition alongside
taoism and Confucianism
and as Buddhism spread to China and
gradually adjusted and accommodated
itself to that cultural climate it came
to develop some truly unique features so
that Chinese or East Asian Buddhism very
much has its own kind of flavor
first of all the kind of Buddhism that
came to China is the branch known as
Mahayana which means great vehicle for
much of History this school has stood
alongside teravada as the two major
branches of the religion with a possible
third inclusion of vajrayana Buddhism
as we talked about in our previous
episode about the Buddhist scholar
nagajuna different regions have been and
still are dominated by different
branches
teravada which means something like the
school of the elders is the dominant
form of Buddhism in places like Cambodia
Thailand Myanmar and Sri Lanka whereas
Mahayana the largest school of Branch
today dominates in places like China
Japan Vietnam Nepal and Malaysia
the history of Buddhism in China is a
long one already during the Han Dynasty
in the last centuries BC Buddhist monks
had made their way there and in the
first centuries A.D or CE Buddhism was
already a significant presence Buddhist
personalities and texts would make their
way across the Silk Road from India to
the Far East where the many sutras of
the Buddha would gradually be translated
into Chinese
as we saw it was Mahayana Buddhism that
became especially prominent here and by
the 6th to 7th centuries they started
developing homegrown schools and forms
of Buddhism unique to China
mostly these were Scholastic schools
dedicated to the elucidation of Buddhist
scriptures such as the Tian Thai School
known in Japan as tendai the Hawaiian or
flower ornament and the famous tingtu or
pure land Buddhism which is still very
strong today and it was in this same
environment that Chan developed which we
will get to soon Buddhism in China and
East Asia really is unique in many ways
even though it shares many core features
with other forms of the religion there
developed new ideas and specific things
were emphasized here probably partly in
response to the already existing local
religions and culture
when we talk about Mahayana Buddhism or
East Asian Mahayana in particular there
are a few things that are Central and
which really characterize this kind of
Buddhism primarily the bodhisattva ideal
and the teachings about Buddha nature
the ideal of the bodhisattva is one of
the main things that distinguishes
Mahayana from theravada indeed while the
goal for a theravada Buddhist is
essentially to become an arhat to reach
nirvana and be liberated from samsara
the cycle of death and rebirth Mahayana
has another goal which is essentially
focused on compassion
the highest aim is to become a
bodhisattva a borisatva is a person that
has attained Awakening but still decides
to so to say stay in the world of change
to help others reach Awakening with the
ultimate goal of everyone eventually
being liberated
there are many bodhisattvas in this
system and they often take on a role
similar to deities and other religions
the goal here isn't to quote unquote
escape the world but to live
compassionately and virtuously in it
something that will also be very
important in Chan Buddhism in particular
in fact in a lot of Chinese Buddhism the
whole concept of Nirvana is interpreted
in a way that is surprising to many
there is in fact no Nirvana as
understood as a particular State event
or happening
Nirvana isn't some otherworldly place or
state of experience a Liberation from
this world instead Nirvana is all of
this right now everything is nirvana all
the time this brings us to that second
characteristic of Chinese Mahayana
Buddhism the idea of Buddha nature
at its core this is essentially the idea
that Liberation is available to everyone
at all times it isn't just specific
people who have access to it those who
have lived a certain collection of past
lives and accumulated the karma required
to reach it it isn't just monks who
spend their whole life meditating in a
monastery everyone can reach Awakening
and right now this is because everything
takes part in Buddha nature everyone is
a potential Buddha because the very
nature of the Buddha and of Liberation
is present everywhere including in
ourselves
this Doctrine which is often known as
tataga tagarba has been interpreted
differently by different schools of
Buddhism but the basic idea remains and
while the term I just used is sanskrit
and precursors to the idea may have
appeared in India it is an idea that is
strongly associated with Chinese and
East Asian Buddhism in particular but in
general the ideas of Buddha nature are
strongly connected to the concept of
emptiness or shunyata which we have
explored deeply in a previous episode
Buddhism teaches that everything is
non-permanent that is it temporary
everything is always changing it also
posits the idea of no self that there is
no inherent self or core to human beings
or ultimately to anything
the idea of the eye or the self as a
fixed independent reality is an illusion
the doctrine of emptiness Associated
primarily with the Thinker nagajuna went
even further by stating that everything
is empty there are no Essences in the
world at all
now it should be remembered that
emptiness does not mean nothingness
instead what emptiness teaches is that
all things are interdependent on all
other things
there is no independent reality or
Essence to anything because any quote
unquote thing we imagine is only a
series of happenings related to other
things
the necessary consequence of the fact
that everything is empty is its backside
that everything is everything else
that any single thing is simultaneously
all of reality because it partakes of an
infinitely interconnected web of events
in other words it's a kind of
non-dualism but one that neglects any
idea of a absolute reality as such such
as the Brahman of Hinduism it is very
even nagarjuna in his writings are they
are very careful not to posit that there
is this Ultimate Reality similar to to
the to the Brahman or the Atman in
Hinduism there is no Ultimate Reality
nothing has independent or fixed
existence as such everything is empty
but since everything is connected and
everything is interdependent on
everything else there's a kind of
non-duality inherent in that idea too
when we look at a tree there is no tree
there as in a specific thing called the
tree
that's only a mental Construction
on the other hand the positive outcome
of that is that when we look at a tree
we're looking at something that is
infinitely connected to everything else
that tree would not be what it is
without the soil from which it grows
without the Sun that gives it light and
enables it to grow without the planet's
specific distance from the Sun that
gives it just the right heat to be able
to grow the Sun and its particular place
in the galaxy and literally everything
else which together make that tree what
it is and with that which it would be
nothing
in other words when we look at the tree
we are looking simultaneously at
emptiness at no thing at all and we are
looking at a particular manifestation
and showing of the entirety of reality
appearing at that specific moment as
something we call a tree
in any case because everything is
interconnected in this way every
individual quote-unquote thing being
part of everything else this has
significant consequences because after
all the Buddha lived at one point and
since the Buddha lived and achieved
Liberation everything is the Buddha and
everything is Liberation because
everything is interconnected and
everything contains everything else that
means that everything contains Nirvana
and Buddha in other words the Buddha
nature
this is why Liberation is available to
anyone it's right here all the time not
in some distant place or other world but
right here and now
this idea of Buddha nature as a common
feature of all reality is a central
aspect of Chinese Buddhism and shows up
in slightly different ways in all the
schools of Buddhism that would emerge
here now the school that we know as Chan
developed in this very fruitful period
of religious and philosophical activity
that we have discussed around the 6th
through 9th centuries and in many ways
it's a kind of response to the
approaches of the other schools
there are two ways in which we can
approach the history and origins in
particular of Chan Buddhism the
scholarly
historically critical one and the
traditional internal one because indeed
the way that the history of chamber
Buddhism is told within the tradition
itself contains many aspects that we
would consider
legendary or at least semi-legendary and
stories and aspects that is or that are
very hard to to verify with you know the
historical critical method that we can
be sure are true or not myths for
example according to this classical
account there is a direct line of Chan
Patriarchs that stretches back all the
way to the Buddha himself so the Chand
Buddhism puts a huge emphasis on on
lineage and teaches student relationship
and they believe that this lineage of
teachers goes back all the way to the
Buddha much of this is hard to verify
scientifically though when many scholars
today
instead hold the view that Sean Buddhism
actually emerged in a more eclectic way
different meditation Masters in
different parts of China with similar
outlooks around the 6th 7th Century that
sort of grew and eventually so coalesced
into into a unified school in a certain
sense and these stories about the
Patriarchs are probably projections
later on to to sort of unify and and
create a more coherent story of the
origins of the tradition nonetheless
these are the two kind of different
versions of of the story but if we
explore the traditional accounts in
particular while of course keeping in
mind the some of the questionable
historicity we found some really
fascinating stories and and characters
that are at the core of the history and
origins of John Buddhism Chan traces its
lineage to the Buddha himself of course
but in particular to one of his
prominent followers mahakashapa
he was an important figure in the
earliest Buddhist community and is often
seen as the first Chan or zen master and
often told story really encapsulates
this role of his and some of the basics
of Chan teachings
in this story the Buddha gathers his
followers to hold a talk or a speech
but the eager students are surprised
when the Buddha doesn't say anything at
all
instead just sitting there in complete
silence holding up a flower in his hand
everyone is perplexed and tries to
understand what's going on is the Buddha
sick is this a kind of trick of some
sort
everyone that is except mahakashipa
instead when he sees the Buddha holding
up the flower in silence he breaks into
a smile
the Buddha then Praises him saying that
he's the only one that is truly
understood his teachings
this really says something about Chan
and its characteristic teachings in
contrast to other schools it doesn't
Place its emphasis on words or texts or
philosophizing but on a kind of wordless
wisdom achieved through direct
experience meditation and insight
transmitted directly from a teacher to a
student rather than from texts or
teaching through words the story of the
flower sermon as it has become known
thus serves as a kind of archetype for
chant teachings in a way and claims
mahakashapa as its original
representative but Chan as such Doesn't
truly begin until much later from around
the 6th century and in China
its development is associated with a few
Patriarchs often six in particular
founding figures that made the school
what it is
the first of these is often said to be
the figure body Dharma
followed by dazo huike yanchi sengchan
Dai daochin Daman hongren and daijan Hui
ning
it might be worthwhile to explore that
first patriarch body Dharma a bit
further since he is so foundational and
frankly just really fascinating
body Dharma is actually a kind of
semi-legendary figure it isn't entirely
certain that he was a historical person
and if he was the stories about him are
dubious in terms of historicity
in any case it is thought that he lived
in the 5th or 6th century and came from
the West either from India or maybe
Central Asia after training as a
Buddhist monk he was tasked to go to
China and spread the tradition there
representing a direct lineage the 28th
person in a lineage going back to the
Buddha himself he would establish what
would become known as Chan Buddhism in
China
in one story he is taken to Emperor Wu
of the Liang Dynasty who asks him what
is the true meaning of Buddhism
says something to the effect that
Buddhism has nothing to do with true and
false
the emperor is taken aback by this and
asks what is the purpose or Merit then
for his sponsoring the building of
temples translations of scriptures and
other projects
but the Dharma simply replies that it
has no merit at all and the emperor is
shocked
having upset the emperor the patriarch
then leaves probably smart and it is
said that he went to mount song where he
would sit in meditation facing a wall
for nine years
body Dharma would then serve as the
archetype and key figure in the
emergence of Chan with its focus on
meditation in particular
there are many stories sayings and texts
attributed to him but it's hard to say
how much is accurate many modern
Scholars argue however that a work
entitled something like two entrances
and four practices can probably be
attributed at least partly to the man
himself if he was a historical person in
this text we find the characteristic
teachings of bodhidharma much of which
would become important to Chan as a
whole
as the title suggests there are two
entrances to the Buddhist path principle
and practice
principle is simply that one realizes
reality for what it is the emptiness of
all things to see past the illusions of
our regular mind
bodhidharma says himself quote to enter
by principle means to realize the
essence through instruction and to
believe that all living things share the
same true nature which isn't apparent
because it's shrouded by sensation and
delusion
the second entrance of practice involves
four practices as the title of the
Treatise also suggests while there can
be some variants in terms of how these
are translated they are generally
accepting apparent Injustice
corresponding with or kind of accepting
present conditions seeking nothing
including not seeking Awakening or
liberation
and expressing the Dharma for the
benefit of others
these teachings as well as those that
his successors would add and contribute
to it are some of the core features of
Chan Buddhism
so what is it that makes Chan or Zen
Buddhism what it is what is unique about
it among other Buddhist schools even in
China we have already answered some of
those questions and it's not an easy
subject to tackle but the basic
characteristics of Chan Buddhism is
first and foremost this focus on a
lineage of Masters some Scholars have
argued that this is a direct result of
the very strong ancestor cult in Chinese
culture which was then adapted in this
way to the Buddhist tradition whatever
the case this idea of lineage is highly
emphasized as well as the
teacher-student relationship in general
Chan is a kind of response to these
Scholastic schools of Buddhism that
dominated China at the time the schools
that focused on interpreting texts from
India in Chan Awakening or wisdom is not
reached through words or teachings as
such but through wordless experience and
virtuosity taught directly by a teacher
the last of the Chon Patriarchs Hui Nang
is thought to have said that quote a
finger points at the moon but the Moon
is not at the tip of the finger words
point at the truth but the truth is not
in words
the goal is not to be liberated to enter
some otherworldly States or to be
concerned with the rituals or word word
related teachings or such things instead
the goal of Chan practice and Liberation
is something to be lived a way of being
in the world and in relationship to
other people and beings
The Scholar Peter D hershock says quote
practicing Chan is not a spiritual
discipline that requires us to retreat
into a cave or a remote Forest it is a
way of being present that can and
finally must be undertaken in the midst
of everyday circumstances it is not an
exercise of single poignant
concentration but of Illuminating and
bringing to full expression the
enlightening character and non-duality
of all things
when people imagine Chan or Zen they
tend to imagine a monk sitting in
meditation for a long period of time
indeed as we said in the beginning this
is often the image of Buddhism in
general that many people have
that meditation is indeed very important
to Chan
the word chan after all comes from the
Sanskrit dhyana meaning meditation and
that is often mentioned as one of the
things that characterize it the most
chance focus on meditation
the emergence of the tradition of Chan
can be said to have been a Loosely
connected group of meditation Masters as
we saw with bodhidharma for example now
meditation is of course present in
basically all Buddhist schools at least
in some way it was after all through
meditation under the body tree that the
Buddha himself reached nirvana
but Buddhist Meditation can take many
different forms not all of which is
simply sitting still and focusing on
your breathing or emptying your mind for
example
a lot of Buddhist Meditation is a lot
more involved and complex than that
involving chanting sutras or
visualization and other techniques but
in Chan or Zen there is a particular
focus on that kind of meditation that we
are most familiar with what is called in
the tradition
or in Chinese zazen which translates as
sitting meditation
this is a kind of meditation where you
do precisely what it sounds like simply
sitting often with open eyes facing a
wall or sometimes with eyes closed
sometimes specific things are focused on
to help concentration such as a breath
but the basic idea is simply to sit
involves specific postures such as the
Lotus position and the image of a Zen
monk meditating is perhaps one of the
most iconic images associated with
Buddhism this kind of meditation existed
in other schools as well but often this
form of meditation was simply an initial
technique to prepare or calm the mind
for the actual meditations that followed
which would often be a lot more involved
in Chan instead this particular form is
emphasized as a primary practice but why
how come this practice is so important
to Chon in particular if you remember
what I mentioned earlier East Asian
Buddhism and therefore Chan has some
characteristic teachings including very
significantly that of Buddha nature
everything has Buddha nature and
Enlightenment as its own very nature
suffering and Nirvana are one and the
same thing and everything is Buddha
nature
Enlightenment is right there in front of
us the whole time it's not some sort of
gradual Journey where we leave
everything behind and eventually Reach
This High State it's eternally present
the whole time as our very nature
everything that keeps us from being
awakened are all things that we have
added to our nature all the things we
misunderstand about ourselves that get
in the way of realizing the fact that
our self is illusory and that all things
are empty
as such to reach Enlightenment all we
need to do is let go of those false
constructs we have added to ourselves
and to Simply recognize what was there
all along what was truly there which is
identical to Nirvana
when we sit in meditation in zazan we
simply allow ourselves to be
to where the analytic mind is silenced
and we can hopefully fall into an
unobstructed vision of ourselves and
there is Awakening
when sitting in meditation we aren't
supposed to focus on anything at all in
particular we aren't doing anything at
all not even meditating
it's actually a kind of non-meditation
the whole purpose of sitting in
meditation
is to sit in meditation
there is no goal or ultimate purpose
other than the very action itself
sitting
if we do that properly we can fall into
an unobstructed way of being where all
the constructs about who we are and what
all of this is Falls away and we awaken
to the Nirvana that was there all along
according to tradition someone once
asked the first John patriarch body
Dharma where is the place of
enlightenment
to which he replied quote the place you
are walking on is to play some
Enlightenment the place you are lying on
is to play some Enlightenment the place
you are sitting is the place of
Enlightenment the place you are standing
is the place of enlightenment
wherever you pick up your feet or put
them down that is the place of
enlightenment
indeed the common understanding of
Nirvana that most people would have if
you ask a random person on the streets
it's actually false according to the
school usually when we ask someone what
Nirvana is they will say that Nirvana is
the ending of suffering or the the
somehow that the person has reached the
state where he transcends suffering
somehow but this is actually not true at
least according to this interpretation
even after reaching Nirvana we still
experience the world and everything in
it just as it is including suffering we
don't stop hurting when someone punches
Us in the face we don't stop feeling sad
when a family member or a friend passes
away and we feel that terrible sense of
loss that's all still experienced
instead Nirvana is simply The
Disappearance of any resistance to
suffering and a resistance to pain it is
after all often resistance to suffering
that is the most painful if we fully
accept a situation that we are in
um or any suffering or pain that we are
feeling it becomes at least less
difficult to go through in other words
it is to some degree our state of mind
that determines our experience it's the
Core teaching of Chan Buddhism that is
our state of mind that determines our
well how we experience the world
including how we experience suffering or
in this case not experience suffering
because we don't
attach any will to ending suffering for
example we just let things be as they
are and when we do that we stop
suffering even from things like pain I
remember one time I was walking home in
the middle of winter at night with two
large bags in my hands I had quite a
long way to go before I came home and it
was really freezing outside I could
already tell as I was walking in that my
hands were starting to hurt from that
from the from the cold it was terrible I
was having a just an awful time but
suddenly I realized you know
it's gonna take me a while to get home
there's nothing I can do about this I'm
going to be cold it's going to hurt
and I simply accepted the fact that my
hands are going to hurt a lot in in the
coming 15 minutes
once I accepted that
while the pain didn't necessarily go
away I completely stopped suffering from
that pain to some degree it wasn't a
problem for me anymore because I had
completely accepted that things were
going to hurt and when I accepted that
it was a lot more bearable I don't mean
to say that I've reached nirvana of
course but to point out there is often
resistance to suffering or being
attached to a certain outcome that
creates suffering and to be rid of all
such resistance and attachments is
something close to what is meant by
Nirvana here it is from this that
another characteristic teaching in Chan
comes the idea of sudden Awakening
rather than like in most other schools
of Buddhism the road to Enlightenment is
a gradual Journey where we let go of
attachments and Illusions until we find
Awakening in Chan Awakening happens all
at once and suddenly because Nirvana is
right here all the time when we awaken
to it we do it suddenly
that isn't to say of course that Chan
doesn't involve practice or isn't a
difficult path to reaching that state
but the event of Awakening itself is
looked at very differently quote
if we find ourselves in the position of
wanting Liberation or Awakening we are
already stuck in delusion
if Awakening lies Somewhere Over the
Horizon of our present situation in some
other time or some other place then it
is nothing more than a figment of one's
imagination
this is actually a big debate in early
childhood Buddhism with two schools the
Southern and Northern schools are
presenting different perspectives one
favoring sudden Awakening the other
gradual Awakening
eventually the so-called Southern School
represented by the last of these six
Patriarchs queeneng became the Paradigm
and sudden Enlightenment would
characterize most of Chan from then on
so meditation or sitting meditation is
one of the core practices that
characterized Chan Buddhism
another core concept associated with the
tradition which is also partly connected
to the doctrine of sudden Enlightenment
is the employment of gong on or Koons in
Japanese
these are literally public cases often
misunderstood as riddles but really they
are stories or short sentences sometimes
stories of the Chan Patriarchs or other
such things that have the aim of
rattling the mind the koans are to be
meditated on and are often very
confusing or strange without any
seemingly clear answer
they always have an answer though and a
prominent tradition in Chan especially
in the linji and rinzai school is that
students are given a koan and are tasked
with presenting an answer to their
Master a process that can take a long
time and many attempts before being
completed some of these koans have
become famous even outside a Buddhist
framework such as the question what is
the sound of one hand clapping or when
lingi one of the great masters of Chan
Buddhism is thought to have said if you
see the Buddha on the road kill him
a Quran in the best cases can break the
mind so to say it can jolt the person
out of his regular way of looking at
things and lead to a sudden Awakening
there are stories of the Patriarchs
having such experiences being told
something just someone telling saying a
sentence and the person just reaching
Enlightenment right away from hearing
that sentence this is a common kind of
thing in Chan or Zen Buddhism so these
are some of the key features of Chan or
Zen Buddhism in particular
but this can sometimes also be
misleading
it is true that meditation both sitting
meditation and Quran meditation is
essential practice but as we said
earlier the ultimate goal in Mahayana in
general is not to become liberated and
end the cycle of rebirths remember
Nirvana and suffering are one in the
same thing sitting meditation is great
and can be very helpful but according to
many Chan Buddhists true practice is a
kind of non-practice
it is to cultivate a mind that lives
virtuously in the world being able to
meet basically any situation with
spontaneous Genius Like a master
musician who has cultivated his playing
to such a level that he never has to
think about what he's playing he simply
does it effortlessly the chuchan master
is a person who confronts all of life in
this way being able to respond
appropriately to any situation without
obstruction and live an awakened life in
relationship to other people in a way
everything is thus meditation
in Chan there is the idea that even the
most mundane tasks are also meditation
when approached correctly something that
resembles the modern idea of mindfulness
there is a Zen saying that basically
goes when you're walking walk when
you're eating eat
in other words every situation however
ordinary and mundane it may be is to be
approached with total presence and Care
ideally with as little obstruction and
effort as possible
this is why you will see Zen monks
frequently doing things like raking
leaves or washing the dishes even in
washing your dirty plates Awakening or
Nirvana is present and is a perfect
opportunity for meditation
ideally every moment of life is a kind
of meditation
now many of these ideas especially these
latter ones might remind you of other
Chinese traditions such as taoism and
this is a very significant Point
Buddhism of course adapted and changed
depending on the environment into which
it spread and this was equally true in
China
local Traditions like taoism and
Confucianism undeniably had an effect on
East Asian forms of Buddhism
and when it comes to Chan it is often
said that this is the school where we
can most clearly see influences from
taoism in particular
many of the characteristic features of
Chan such as the focus on unobstructed
mind and virtuous spontaneity in life
have clear parallels in taoism and in
the classic literature of that tradition
such as in the Dao de Jing or the dronsu
not just these techniques either but
also some meditation techniques in
general as well as the fact that the
idea of Buddha nature is in some ways
pretty similar to the idea of the Dao I
have even encountered people who claim
that the Chan Buddhists are the true
heirs or successors to the early
so-called philosophical taoists like
laozzi and Johnson which is often placed
in you know in contrast to later
religious taoism now I completely
disagree with these categories as a
whole but it really shows you how much
Chand Buddhism in particular seems to
have in common or have have taken
inspiration perhaps from the early
Taoist literature it's a fascinating
topic but it shouldn't be overemphasized
too much either John differs in
significant ways too and the
relationship between the two Traditions
were not always on friendly terms with
many episodes of Oppression of Buddhists
and vice versa the Patriarchs and early
representatives of Chan and China shaped
much of the tradition of course and we
have discussed some of those key
features but the school also continued
to evolve and develop over time
even within Chan different sub-schools
emerge that differed on certain fronts
not to mention the differences between
geographical divisions such as Zen son
and Tien there were various sub-schools
of charm that emerged in the Middle Ages
not all of which we have time to dive
into here there's often talk about the
five houses of Chan five recognized Chan
lineages that emerged during the Song
Dynasty often considered the Golden Age
of Chan Buddhism essentially only two of
these schools have survived to any
significant degree the cow dong school
and the lingi school
to this day Chan Buddhism is generally
divided into these two major schools or
branches so what are the differences
well at its core it's simply a question
of lineage but they've also emphasized
different things historically there is
no way of talking about this without
just completely oversimplifying
everything but one thing that is often
said is that the cow dong School focuses
more on sitting meditation and Silent
illumination this school is thought to
have been founded by the figures
dongshan Liang ji and kaoshang Benji and
the name Cow dong being a kind of
combination of their names this is at
least one Theory
there's a major focus in the school on
those zazen techniques that we mentioned
earlier the cancer meditation that are
non-meditation where the goal is simply
to sit
the other lean G school is named after
the Indie yichuan who is considered the
defining figure in that lineage
he and his successors became famous
among other things for Sometimes using
violence in their teaching techniques a
master could actually strike a student
to jolt him out of his regular state of
mind and help them Reach Enlightenment
it's also generally said that this goal
is more focused on the koans meditating
on these stories or these cons and the
more ritualized aspects of the students
you know discussing contemplating and
giving answers to qurans to their master
and the school sometimes instead has
less so focus on silent meditation like
the cow dong school but again these are
all huge generalizations
the Lindy school has been the dominant
for most of History
these schools are perhaps better known
in the west however by their Japanese
names or equivalents
as Chan Buddhism eventually spread to
Japan and became known as Zen these
different schools also came to have a
presence there
and in Japan the Lindy School became
known as rinzai or rinzai Zen whereas
the cow dong School became known as Soto
Sen
the man responsible for bringing
soto-sen to Japan is perhaps the most
famous Zen Buddhist in history Dogan
zenji dorgan was originally from Japan
and earlier in his life was an ordained
monk in the Scholastic Tian Thai School
known in Japan as tendai but he became
dissatisfied with their teachings and
eventually traveled to China where he
studied Chan
specifically the cow dong School Upon
returning to Japan a few years later he
brought this school with him and
established it in his native country
where it became known as Soto
in his teachings and extensive writings
which included the Masterworks
showbogenzo treasury on the true Dharma
eye he put a major emphasis on zazen
sitting meditation
specifically in the form often called
shikantasa in Japanese which translated
as something like nothing but sitting we
talked about this concept earlier as
common to all of Zen but dogen seems to
put an even bigger emphasis on it
the idea is that zazen meditation as the
core practice of Zen and technique for
Liberation is simply about sitting it is
that non-meditation that has no specific
purpose other than to Simply Be and with
no specific technique
this is the famous idea associated with
Dogan that the practice is the goal it
is only through this kind of
non-meditation that we can get an
unobstructed experience of our true
nature and the nature of all things that
nature which is after all identical to
Nirvana
dogen and his teachings have
characterized Zen particularly Soto sen
in Japan for the rest of history and a
lot of our ideas about Zan here in the
west are also strongly colored by the
influence of dogen in particular similar
to China the Soto and rinzai schools
have been the dominant forms of Zen
Buddhism in Japan but these in
themselves are of course divided into
their own branches and sub-branches and
so on in many ways the Zen tradition of
Japan differs from Chan in China even
though they have a common origin
indeed the different geographical
schools Chan in China Zen in Japan sawn
in Korea and Tien in Vietnam were often
considered separate traditions of their
own since they have often developed
independently of each other across
history and being colored by local
traditions and contexts we don't have
time to go through all these differences
and nuances here of course but it's an
interesting point to consider if you
visit a Japanese Zen Center in Europe or
North America compared to a Chinese Chan
Center there can be significant
differences between the two today one
such difference that is often brought up
between you know Chinese Chan and
Japanese Zen is that Zen Buddhists in
Japan have at least since the Meiji
restoration or
revolution in the 19th century Zen monks
are allowed to marry so they will often
have families and children while also
being Zen monks whereas in China and in
the Chan tradition so to say the monks
still generally take a vow of celibacy
but Zen hasn't just spread to other
parts of East Asia but also to the West
especially in the last century
indeed Zen is one of the most famous and
prominent forms of Buddhism that we find
in a western context
it seems to really appeal to a European
and American audience perhaps partly due
to its somewhat iconoclastic nature
compared to other schools of Buddhism it
isn't as ritualistic or focused on
Sacred Scriptures thus appearing to be
less quote unquote religious according
to Western conceptions
that is my favorite list
Zen is more egalitarian too it doesn't
require you to become a monk or study
scriptures deeply to understand the
doctrines of Buddhism it simply tells us
to sit and be what we are something that
is available to everyone and which
doesn't sound all that difficult
although as many of you probably know
just simply sitting is easier said than
done
many of the famous Buddhist teachers who
had a significant presence in the west
come from the Chan tradition in
particular for example the popular
teacher tiknat Han who passed away last
year belonged to the Vietnamese Tien
School in conclusion Chan Buddhism has
been one of the dominant and most
influential schools of Buddhism in East
Asia and lately also across the whole
world
its teachings appeared partly as a kind
of respond to the scholasticism of its
fellow Chinese schools and instead
emphasize teachers student transmission
wordless teachings direct experience and
sitting silent meditation it teaches the
profound idea that Nirvana is available
to anyone at any time since the Buddha
nature is our own very reality and can
be awakened to by simply looking past
all the constructions of our mind to
where our unobstructed view of our true
nature leads to a sudden Awakening to
Nirvana
a Nirvana there is not some other
worldly state but simply a way of being
in this world a way of confronting the
happenings of Life suffering and all
with virtuosity and compassion for all
fellow beings
some of its characteristic features such
as zazen meditation and koans have
become famous around the world outside
of Buddhism and can even provide
spiritual meaning to the secular modern
person certainly then Chan or Zen is a
significant piece of the puzzle when we
try to understand the vast and
significant tradition that is Buddhism
as always I would like to thank all my
patrons for supporting this channel
without whom I would not be able to do
any of this and so I I owe everything to
to my supporters over on patreon I would
highly appreciate if anyone else wanted
to become a supporter of this channel so
I will leave links to all that stuff in
the description and in append comment
you can also support this channel by
making a one-time donation through
PayPal or simply through liking
commenting or subscribing to the channel
which obviously helps a lot so thank you
all so much for watching
and I'll see you next time
[Music]
foreign